in this video we'll talk about multiple
sclerosis or ms
sclerosis means scar so multiple
sclerosis means car over different
location of the central nervous system
the lesions are present
in the brain and in the spinal cord
multiple sclerosis is kind of like a
progressive demyelination
so in this case the white matter of the
brain and spinal cords get seriously
affected
and this progression of this disease is
really slow and often takes decades
and the demyelination is triggered by
immunological reactions there are
autoreactive
cells which can actually affect these
myelin sheath of the neurons which work
like a insulator
the structures
that are usually involved in
multiple sclerosis are actually the
components of cns
generally the optic and the oculomotor
nerves are actually affected also the
spinal nerve tract is affected but this
disorder does not affect the peripheral
nervous system that's the most important
part
so there are several symptoms which
includes vision problems which can be
understood because optic nerve tract is
affected lesions can develop there
numbness and tingling walking difficulty
dizziness weakness fatigue
cognitive dysfunction all of these
symptoms are associated with multiple
sclerosis
now let's talk about the key symptoms
this involves dysarthria which means
difficulty or unclear speech
because this
scars can also occur in the brain stem
and brain stem is crucial for
speech and look of speech and
communication that's why there could be
speech related problems
another symptom could be nystagmus that
means involuntary and rapid eye movement
and you know the optic
nerve tract and oculomotor nerve tract
is damaged in case of multiple sclerosis
probably this leads to this kind of
situation
this can lead to blurred vision double
vision or even other visual difficulties
lastly there could be intention tremors
that means
this there could be like tremors
developing due to lesions in the motor
pathways
all these three major symptoms are
collectively known as
the charcot's neurologic triad in
multiple sclerosis
now let's talk about the risk factors
associated with multiple sclerosis there
could be genetic as well as
environmental factors
so there are genetic factors such as
it has been shown that people who are
showing defects in their hla dr or hla
dq locus which are associated with class
2 mhc molecules
they show
more susceptibility towards developing
multiple sclerosis
also environmental factors such as viral
infections can also increase the risk of
multiple sclerosis or or are associated
with multiple sclerosis
let us talk about few more environmental
factors sunlight and vitamin d plays a
crucial role so overall you can
understand diet is important
and there is a overall factor that women
are more susceptible than man and this
is also because of a genetic factor
it has been shown the occurrence of
multiple sclerosis is much more in those
region
which has low sunlight and thereby
people have low vitamin d that means it
is lesser in the equator and it there
the incidence rise when we go away from
the equator and this heat map gives you
a quick idea
multiple sclerosis pathology is
characterized by confluent demyelited
areas
so this is how a healthy blend look like
and this is how a ms brain look like
in this case you can first see there are
cortical demyelination but cortical
demyelination takes some time and
happens in the advanced stage of this
disease initially the scars or the
lesions appears in the white matter and
these are detectable in mri imaging
and these scars are occurring due to the
defect or destruction of the myelin
sheath and the oligodendrocyte which
forms this myelin sheath
let's talk about the subtypes of
multiple sclerosis
so if we plot the percentage disability
in the y-axis and the age or the
timeline in the x-axis then the graphs
would look like this
this first type is known as relapsing
remitting multiple sclerosis
i'll come to it in a bit more details
the second type is known as secondary
progressive uh
multiple sclerosis then there is primary
progressive and progressive relapsing
all these are really important but the
most common one is the
rrms or relapsing remitting multiple
sclerosis here
there are bouts of autoimmune attacks
and that
is kind of spaced between months or
years so there are aggravation of this
disease
over time
and the secondary progressive multiple
sclerosis has a steady progression of
disability in the later half of this
particular disease
and in case of primary progressive
multiple sclerosis there is constant
attack on the myelin sheath so rapidly
rapidly the myelin sheaths are degraded
so disease progression is relatively
faster in this type of multiple
sclerosis
and progressive relapsing is even faster
so there are like continuous attack but
in bouts the attack becomes even more
severe
now let's talk about the immunology of
multiple sclerosis
so generally the t cells develop in the
thymus
but in the thymus there are mechanisms
known as central tolerance which
prevents the generation of autoreactive
t cells even in outside the thymus there
are peripheral tolerance which ensures
there are no autoreactive t cells which
could be harmful for the body but for
multiple sclerosis this tolerance
mechanism fails if you want to know more
about tolerance you can click on the
video in the i button
and that leads to many complications
there are too many autoreactive t cells
in the circulation they can ultimately
cross the blood brain barrier and can
enter the brain so the brain is no more
immune privileged and that is pretty
dangerous
inside the brain
there are several things that happens
so
in the myelin sheath there are antigens
such as myelin basic protein
proteolypic protein myelin
oligodendrocyte a glycoprotein all of
these antigens are detected by these
autoreactive t cells autoreactive t
cells actually
uh kind of get activated and
affect the myelin sheath
now there are infiltrating uh
antigen presenting cells which further
present these antigens to these t cells
now this aggravates the reaction
these t cell once get activated secrete
several other subtypes such as th1 or
th17
both of these t cells are highly
associated with inflammatory processes
they can secrete cytokines such as
interleukin 1 6 t
tnf alpha etc
now
overall
there are
th1 and th17 subtypes are associated
with multiple sclerosis and current
research shows there could be
one particular dominant population but
it's kind of debatable at this moment
anyway there could be other factors
which are affecting uh the disease
progression such as the regulatory t
cells regulatory t cells generally
prevent the activity of
any kind of authority or any kind of t
cells by producing the
cytokine interleukin-10 so it's kind of
like a speed breaker
but
in case of multiple sclerosis often it
was observed that the regulatory t cell
function is abrogated
that leads to further increase in
autoreactive t cell activity
that can be damaging for the brain
so let's talk about how can we diagnose
multiple sclerosis one of the option is
to look for clinically relevant
biomarkers and that can be done by
taking out the csf by lumber puncture
and analyzing the csf for several
biomarkers like myelin basic protein igm
oligoclonal bands
neural adhesion molecules and many other
factors
so these biomarkers can help us to
predict whether there is a
chance of developing multiple sclerosis
or not then the best way is to do by
magnet uh magnetic resonance imaging or
mri and this is the most useful test
diagnostic tool for multiple sclerosis
classically mri will show
lesions in the white matter in the brain
and that is pretty characteristic of
multiple sclerosis
currently there is no treatment for
multiple sclerosis but there are
supportive treatment and
immunosuppressants which can help
the patient to have a better lifestyle
or like it can reduce the pain
so it's kind of like a supportive
medicine but there is no absolute cure
for this particular disease
so i hope this video was useful if you
like this video give it a big thumbs up
you can get notes and flash cards
associated with many videos in my
facebook page the link is provided in
the description as usual don't forget to
like share and subscribe you can support
me on patreon or if you're indian viewer
then you can support me on beam upi app
my courses are also present in an
academy which is india's biggest online
learning platform you